now because the system of the experience
of spirit embraces only the appearance
of spirit the advance from the system to
the science of the true in its true
shape seems to be merely negative and
one might wish to be spared the negative
as something false and to demand to be
led to the truth without more ado why
bother with the false the view already
discussed namely that we should begin
with science straight away is to be
answered at this point by examining the
nature of the negative in general
regarded as what is false this is a
topic regarding which established ideas
notably obstruct the approach to truth
it will give us occasion to speak of
mathematical cognition in which unfill
Asafa chol knowledge regards as the
ideal that philosophy must strive to
attain though it has so far striven in
vain
we are now roughly at the halfway mark
in the preface to the phenomenology of
spirit and we've run through a number of
very important themes and Hegel has
developed some of them fully most of
them not entirely and we're gonna see
them show up as we move into the second
half of the preface in section 38 he is
going to talk about negativity again and
science system appearance phenomena and
truth and falsity and he's going to
continue this discussion of truth of the
true and the false of truth and falsity
through the next several passages the
next several paragraphs but it's going
to run throughout the entire
phenomenology and he's made this point
that he's been a stress here in this
paragraph before earlier on but now he's
going to reinforce it so the question is
why bother with the false and that
that's a good question with a lot of
things we could say look what human
progress really consists in is not
having to mess around with doing
everything from the ground up not having
to go through the entirety of an
experience why shouldn't we just profit
from the crystallized and reflected upon
experience of others and for many things
that actually works quite well if you
want to go online there's many how-to
videos that you can watch and most of
them are done by experts in their field
ranging from you know how to fix a sink
to how to hotwire a car to how to do
your taxes doing your taxes of course
can be quite complicated but the basic
idea is look once we've actually figured
out the best way to do something or a
good way to do it let's just jump to the
end and Hegel is saying people might be
tempted to do
with the phenomenology after all look at
how thick the book is right why don't we
just go to the very last few pages where
everything has been set out or you know
could we maybe have a chart or an
infographic or maybe instead of having
the half hour Hegel series extending
over all these videos maybe we could
just do it in an hour you know just hit
the bullet points or better yet 20
minutes maybe or about three minutes
because we have these three minute
philosopher videos out there and I don't
actually don't mean to knock the series
it's good for what it does but how much
can you actually get across in three
minutes
Hegel saying there's going to be this
temptation what's been going on he says
the system of the experience of spirit
embraces only the appearance of spirit
so we're doing a phenomenology we're
concerned with what actually appears to
us what shows itself to us the advance
from this system to the science of the
true in its true shape appears to be
merely negative so what are they talking
about there all these shapes of
consciousness that spirit has had to go
through in the course of human history
and development have been negations of
each others or passings of each other
and the question is so we move from this
shape which at it at the time appears to
be you know this is it this is the this
is the best we can do and we've really
achieved something here and then you
know through the process of negation and
the working of the dialectic something
new emerges and then from the advantage
point we can look back we can say wow if
we're being a bunch of jerks we say look
at those dummies those suckers back
there they thought that was the way to
you know actually do things or the way
to think about things in for a bit more
charitable we say they just didn't know
what we know now and we have a better
vantage point from which we can
understand not only the superiority of
this this point to this point but also
why it is that they were not able to see
through to here
you know think for example we're going
to talk about a lot of mathematical
things in the next few paragraphs think
about the development of the integral
calculus which was developed
independently by Isaac Newton and by by
go treat villain alignments who by the
way got themselves into the kind of
philosophical war over who had
plagiarized from who turned out neither
one had and it led to you know
partisanship that actually set British
mathematics behind for quite a while
well well mathematics proceeded better
on the continent because Leiden said a
better notation and because you know
larger number of people working on
things now you can learn the integral
calculus at least the basics of the
theory of limits you know the idea of
function all these important ideas you
can learn that in a calc 1 class and you
don't even have to go to college for
that if you're in a good high school you
might actually get that your senior year
or junior year if you're pretty smart if
you're in European schools you might get
even earlier that took liveness and
Newton incredible efforts of thought to
work that out why didn't a cart work it
out what impossible work it out they
were brilliant men they were brilliant
mathematicians because things have to
advance and so there's this temptation
that's that's inherent in in doing this
phenomenology that's running through
history of saying can't we just skip to
the end can't you just give me the
digested form the fully articulated
unity whatever you want to call it he'll
just give you the the science and don't
bother me with all this historical
background stuff Hegel would say look
buddy it's not just background this is
where it's important that we sort of
look back and recover what has been
going on through this there's a tendency
to see all this is just false it's just
a process of negation or negativity and
to write it off and Hegel says there
would be a big mistake
he says why bother with the false the
view already discussed that we should
begin with science straight away is to
be answered at this point by examining
the nature of the negative in general
regarded as what is false let's not
assume that we automatically know what
truth and falsity is because those are
those are sort of fixed superficial
ideas that we play around with and he
says this is a topic regarding which
established ideas notably obstruct the
approach to truth so a true approach to
truth will actually be one that does
justice to falsity that may sound a
little paradoxical Hegel is also going
to caution us against something that was
prevalent in his time and also rears its
head quite often for us he says it'll
give us occasion to speak of
mathematical cognition which on the
philosophical knowledge regards as the
ideal philosophy must strive to attain
those so far it's driven in vain and
what do we mean by by this mathematical
cognition or mathematical mode of
knowing and presentation well one way to
think about this is in terms of the
quantifiable is everything truly
quantifiable there is an awful lot more
that is quantifiable than people realize
but as just having numbers actually
quantifying something don't the numbers
need to actually match the phenomena
that you're actually talking about not
everything can be measured with a
measuring stick you know think for
example about how political scientists
measure somebody on a spectrum from
conservative to liberal a lot of ad-hoc
assumptions built into that every time
that I go to a political science
conference and watch you know the show
of some of these people presenting the
research as soon as they start asking
soon as they start getting away from the
statistical models I'm talking about how
they actually made the numerical cuts
for this category this category this
category how they quantify things I
start to see wow there's a lot
of jumps a lot of leaps a lot of
assumptions being built in there and so
that's one problem we don't want to jump
over anything or just quantify for the
sake of qualifying there's also the
sense that mathematics can provide us
with absolute certainty about things
that's the way that non mathematicians
tend to look at mathematics as if it's a
kind of magic when you actually get into
mathematics and begin studying it you'll
be struck by several things one is just
how awesome things aren't like the
theory of limits in calculus that's
that's what he actually made me decide
to major math I was taking up a calc 1
class which they put me in and the
teacher explained the theory of limits
and then I was I was hooked but you also
realize that the foundations of
mathematics themselves are rather murky
murkier then then we we think that they
are that there's some paradoxes some
deep paradoxes and involved in it those
were actually realized later on beyond
Hegel's time but Hegel is is right in
calling attention to the sort of
prejudice that people have of thinking
that look if we can reduce things to
axioms or you can quantify or we can you
know have a sort of theory of proof
that'll lead us through a deductive
process or even an inductive process
let's let's you know expand it so long
as we have the theory of probability and
we can you know put things in terms of
statistical problem you know statistical
analyses will be okay and that works for
some things but you can't do a
statistical modeling of how apt a
statistical modeling is you can come up
with confidence intervals true but
there's something about mathematics that
means that it even though it appears to
be like the universal you know
intellectual language so I always a
rather restricted operation that
doing their and spirit is wider than
that
so Hegel wants to caution us about that
true and false belong among those
determinate notions which are held to be
inert and wholly separate essences one
here and one there each standing fixed
and isolated from the other with which
it has nothing in common
against this view it must be maintained
that truth is not a minted coin that can
be given and pocketed ready-made nor is
there such a thing as the false any more
than there is something evil the evil on
the falls to be sure are not as bad as
the devil for in the devil there even
made into a particular subjective agent
as the false and the evil they are merry
universals though each has its own
essence as against the other the false
for here it is only of this that we
speak would be the other the negative of
the substance which as the content of
knowledge is the true but the substance
is itself essentially the negative
partly as a distinction and
determination of the content and partly
a simple distinguishing that is a self
and knowledge in general one can of
course know something falsely to know
something falsely means that there is a
disparity between knowledge and its
substance but this very disparity is the
process of distinguishing in general
which is an essential moment in knowing
out of this distinguishing of course
comes their identity and this resultant
identity is the truth but it is not
truth as if the disparity had been
thrown away like dross from pure metal
not even like a tool which remains
separate from the finished vessel
disparity rather as the negative the
self is still is itself still directly
present in the truest such yet we cannot
therefore say that the false is a moment
of the true let alone a component part
of it to say that in every falsehood
there is a grain of truth is to treat
the two like oil and water which cannot
be mixed and are only externally
combined it is precisely on account of
the importance of designating the moment
of complete other nests that the terms
true and false must no longer be used
where such other n'l
just as to talk of the unity of subject
an object of finite and infinite
infinite of
being thought and so on is inept since
object and subject and those sorts of
things
signify what they are outside of their
unity and since in their unity they are
not meant to be what their expression
says they are just so the false is no
longer qua false a moment of truth
there is a lot of stuff going on here in
in this paragraph 39 and so I I'm
probably gonna have to do a bit of a
racer on the board over the course of
this but I want to keep two ideas two
basic schemas two understandings of
truth and falsity up here so that we so
we can compare them he says and this is
he's starting out with what he thinks is
actually off he says true and false
belong among those determinant notions
which are held held wrongly held held by
those who don't really get it to be
inert and wholly separate essences one
here one there each standing fix and
isolated from the other with which it
has nothing in common and why isn't that
okay you know think about the way that
we handle truth and falsity in formal
logic there they're just values one one
can be a one one can be a zero we can we
can model them that way you know you can
you can actually set up circuits to do
this well that's not the same thing as
truth and falsity in a broader more
encompassing sense you know Hegel is is
not criticizing the you know the
correspondence theory of truth if that's
how you've learned it you know from an
intro to philosophy textbook where truth
is a correspondence between the mind or
language and the thing being thought
about or being being spoken about he's
not criticizing a truth value
you know logical approach to things in
the sense of saying look these are
completely valueless but their value is
within a very narrowly circumscribed
field and they're unable to actually
take into account their own operations
what what it is that actually motivates
them what it is it gives them meaning
there's a bigger concept a bigger
experience of truth more encompassing
more appropriate to spirit as what it is
that human being
surely yes and this is just not going to
cut it for philosophy
truth and falsity are not mere
universals there is something dynamic
about the relationship between truth and
falsity and also something reflexive you
know you could if I depict it this way
say truth and falsity there's a sort of
the separation between them truth is
over here falsities over here and you
know there's nothing in between them is
that true is that a true representation
of that then I've actually interjected
truth right into that boundary in
between them which means that where I
thought truth was not truth actually is
which means that truth is more than what
I originally thought to be which shows
that we're engaged in a dynamic process
here was my original way of thinking
about it therefore false
am i moving from greater truth you know
to greater truth from from greater
falsity how does the falsity exist in
relation to truth can I say that it's
true that there was more falsity you see
all these sort of paradoxes that we can
land ourselves into but when we think in
this way and he says against his view it
must be maintained truth is not a minted
coin that can be given and pocketed
ready-made and again he's you know he's
stressing this about philosophical truth
philosophical truth is something that
requires that we actually do some work
it's not something that you could just
get out of a intro to philosophy text
with you know everything reduced to nice
short bullet points or you know a
handout or something along those lines
those are merely aids they help us on
the way that they're not the actual
truth so he says nor is there such a
thing as the false anymore is there is
something evil the evil and the false
and why is he talking about the devil
here he says they're not as bad as the
devil and the devil they're made into a
particular subjective agent in the fall
as a false and the evil their mere
universals and so you know we can
put over here you know evil negativity
in general you know the point that he
wants to make why would the devil be
considered to be sort of the epitome of
evil because the devil is a subject
there is agency there's an
intentionality there's meaning there's
the destruction of meaning involved
there it's not just a mere empty passive
inert Universal that's available for us
to think about it's something else
personal out there so what should we
counter pose to this Hegel says we want
to actually at a you know if we're going
to think about this in terms of
metaphysics what we want to realize is
that we're actually talking about the
process of negation and it's more
complex than just saying things are true
or they're false and that that's all
there is to it says the false would be
the other the negative of the substance
which is the content of knowledge is the
truth so what we've got here is
something that is being thought of
something that is being understood
something that is being engaged with by
a subject that is trying to make sense
of it that is trying to assimilate it
right and that subject has knowledge of
what that other thing is the substance
that is and that that's what truth at
least at that point consists in so what
where is falsity coming in he says the
substance itself is essentially the
negative partly is a distinction and
determination of content part is you
know simple distinguishing and so we've
got this dialectic up you know every
substance is not just what it appears to
be within a
and phenomenology it's always in
relation to its other which it may even
sort of cast out of itself it gives rise
to its own contradictions which is that
it has to assimilate and we get this
entire cycle going through right and all
parity and negativity is built into that
what about the knowing subjects in
relation to this other does that mean
that this is then if this is true then
this is knowledge of what's false well
this is part of what it is to know the
substance so he says what is it to know
somethin falsely and some people would
say well you can't possibly know
something falsely there's no such thing
as false knowledge you have to
understand here that Hegel understands
knowledge is something which can itself
be dynamic and grow and incorporate and
so it can start off being false and
slowly you know eliminate that falsity
from itself so as to know something
falsely means there's a disparity
between knowledge and it's substance and
we you know we have experiences of this
all the time let me give you just one
example we think that we actually know
somebody and meaning we we understand
the way that they work we know something
about their background we know the tenth
person they are and we get into a
situation with them and oftentimes we'll
say well I didn't really know them at
all and other times they'll say well I I
didn't realize that they have this one
thing about them that led them to be a
complete jerk to be unreliable our
knowledge was not true knowledge of the
subject and if you want to use you know
other terms instead of knowledge and say
well we merely had opinion or Doak so or
pick whatever you like that's fine I
don't think Hegel would quibble with you
there but what Hegel wants to get at is
is to say look when we realize that
there's something that we thought that
we had true knowledge of and then we
realize there's there's a disjunction
us as the knowing subject and what it is
that we're trying to get to know we're
bothered by that we want to try to
overcome that and that itself Spurs us
into this process of trying to grasp how
this substance is actually connected
with its other he says this very
disparity is in the is the process of
distinguishing in general which is an
essential moment in knowing out of this
distinguishing comes the identity of
knowledge and what is is being known and
the resultant identity is truth so truth
is something that grows within the
process so he says it's not as if the
disparity been thrown away like dross
from pure metal not even like the tool
that remains separate from the finished
vessel rather the negative is still
involved in the truth we cannot say that
the false is just a moment of the truth
or even a component of it because then
we're going back to this point of view
where truth and falsity are like oil and
water they just don't mix together you
sort of like separate them out you you
know let something that's emulsified sit
for a while and the oil goes over here
and the the watery parts go over here
like like salad dressing right so he
says it's precisely on account of the
importance of designating the moment of
complete other nests that the terms true
and false are going to be out of place
if we're taking the perspective looking
at things in terms of development then
true and flaws are perfectly appropriate
for us to use just like the other terms
that he's going to talk about in just a
second by way of example when we're
looking at where we get to the hole that
we're cognizant which we're also a part
of that in terms like true and false are
no longer as useful as terms like you
know substance and other nasaw
mega tivity and so he says let's think
of some other terms like this subject an
object finite and infinite
being and thought to talk about the
unity of these so this is an important
point to say that that you know there's
a unity of object and subject Hegel
doesn't want to fall into a kind of
mysticism where like you know like we
said before all calls the night in which
all cows are black
he says object and subjects signify what
they are outside of their unity it's
only insofar as they are something
different from each other
that you can speak of them as object and
subject as having a certain relation
between them the subject cognizant the
ackee of the subject working upon the
object the object resisting the subject
these these sorts of things the subject
desiring the object once they're
actually brought into some sort of unity
if you're taking that perspective it
doesn't make sense to talk of them as
being a unity of subject and object he
would say and the same thing with with
with you know a unity of truth and
falsity so he says the false from that
point of view is no longer as false a
moment of truth